when Carl just destroys Tom that was so
good that was the best scene in the last
episode by far here we go oh yeah let's
read the quote the negative case would
go you're a clumsy interloper Loper so
good you gotta buy rope after that the
only guy pulling for you is dead and now
you're just married to the ex-boss's
daughter and she doesn't even like you
clumsy interloper is so so perfect it
aptly describes Tom specifically yeah
even his retelling of Schiff remember
when we first met yeah I met you in
France yeah and I kept touching you and
I kept asking do you like this do you
like
what the [__] you're [__] interloper
yeah yeah clumsy interloper get out of
here do you like it remember when I
interloped in France I flew to you my
interlude imagine Tom eating your box
dude imagine him eating your truck [__]
yeah do you like this
is this good get away from my truck dude